a new york photographer is using her
talent to celebrate
black history and teach the next
generation about racial justice icons
take a look at these photos you go
tricia messero she uses young models
to recreate powerful images of
trailblazers such as journalists
and activists that's ida b wells and
former south african president and
anti-apartheid leader of the great
nelson mandela
as part of our series unifying america
jericho duncan shows us how these photos
are very helpful
to inspire future leaders
it was a dream come true for 11 year old
terence broughton jr
playing the part of his hero it's almost
like i was
actually seeing what muhammad ali was
seeing there's a whole crowd of people
cheering me on
broughton is one of dozens of kids
chosen by photographer tricia mesaro
to learn about cultural and civil rights
leaders by portraying them
this is about people who matter who
really made
a change giants resized to fit in her
new book
engineers of equality they didn't know
booker t washington they didn't know
claudette calvin they didn't know
us to join the truth were you surprised
you know i wasn't surprised
because growing up i didn't know who
they were
but one name these kids do know george
floyd
whose death was a driving force behind
this project
this is my opportunity to allow kids
to be able to understand and be inspired
and not scared
and so this book is really about
creating that narrative through the eyes
of kids you know through my lens
me and my mom love this moan we mom
eleven-year-old
l scott put her heart into her alter ego
singer and activist nina simone
[Music]
i researched her i watched the
documentary i wanted to make sure i got
it right
what was going through your head in that
moment i'm killing it because
nina simone she didn't think about what
anybody
like thought about her it was that same
grit and determination that
nine-year-old nia thompson found and her
hero
harriet tubman a former slave turned
abolitionist
i was thinking was girl you're playing
harriet tinman and you know how much you
love her and think about the emotions
because you are going to nail this
mesaro photographed 13-year-old jonathan
ridor
as john lewis and this iconic image
meeting jonathan maduro on the edmund
pettus bridge
it hit me right here because you know
the story
you know you know the people it looks
just like john lewis he knew
everything about good trouble what do
you want people to take away from this
project
we're fighting for something more than
just civil rights and voter rights we're
fighting for
not be killed all the time now that i've
like been in this project i love my skin
tone
i love the way i look these are kids who
will probably be leaders one day
and will maybe make a change in the
world
kids capturing not only the image but
the spirit
of their role models for cbs this
morning jerika duncan
baldwin new york i love
the confidence tricia mesrow thank you
for that that was incredible they say
you can't be what you can't see and now
they're embodying these people that's an
amazing way to teach black history
yeah and and to not just be affected by
history but to be making it
yeah and to imagine yourself making it i
love you and i love when i but we're
going to say the same thing when
the little girl said she wanted to make
sure she got it right but she says i'm
killing i'm killing it
exactly but this is the thing that i
thought was so great about it it was
confidence without arrogance it was
confidence filled with a lot of pride
about what they're doing and what it
represents it's beautifully beautifully
done well done